[Music]
dino here
now we're going to learn how to add api
key verification
to any api proxy if you haven't done the
work in the prior video where you
created your first proxy
stop here and go back and watch that
video now
in the apogee ui select the proxy we
created previously
click the develop tab now
click the preflow in the proxy endpoint
and click the plus
step icon scroll down
and select the verify api key policy
click add and done
now i've added api key verification to
my proxy
every request that is received by this
proxy will need to send a key
what happens when i invoke our test
proxy well
you can see i get an error
the apogee proxy is rejecting the
request because i didn't pass an api key
how can we generate a valid api key let
me show you
let's flip back to the apogee ui
the first step is to wrap that proxy in
an api
product in apigee edge
the api product is the way we expose
apis to
consuming developers click the publish
menu
api products click plus
api product name it
and include the api proxy we just
created
click save now we need a developer
normally developers add themselves via
the developer portal but we can also do
it here
in the administrative ui
click publish developers
plus developer specify the relevant
information
now create an app that is authorized for
that product
click publish apps
plus app name the app
select a developer
and add the api product
click save
click back in to see the details and we
see the consumer key
also known as the api key
let's copy that
flip tabs paste in the key as a query
parameter
and invoke the api again you can see the
api proxy is now
allowing the request with the valid api
key
the key ideas here products wrap
api proxies apps have api keys that are
authorized
for specific api products
developers own those apps
in this video we learned the concept of
an api product and we added a verify api
key policy to
our api proxy verify api key is just one
of over 30 policies built into apogee
edge
simply selecting from a drop-down list
you can add policies for traffic
management
security and message manipulation you
can also write custom logic in
javascript or python or even java
if you need something special you have
full control over the request
and response messages there's a lot of
power here
to help you learn about it all don't
forget the documentation and the
community sites
for apogee be sure to watch the next
video in this series
where we'll cover tracing and the
assigned message policy
till then keep it digital